how do you get out of the forest up left
down left takes you right to a graveyard
if you get that reference the forest so
the forest is another ghostly ish movie
that comes out in January every January
they're ghost movies it's almost like
January's the new October this movie
stars Natalie Dormer she finds out that
her twin has daunted this forest in
Japan where people go to commit suicide
she's like I gotta go get her she's not
dead yet and so now she takes a tour
guide into the forest with her and then
the creepies happened that's what we're
here for five minutes into the movie the
creepy things start happening she's not
in the forest yet but you know creepy
imagery and jump scares there were some
jump scares it was kind of irritating
this [ __ ] started five minutes into the
movie I mean to keep this in mind
however long this review is if the start
of this video was the start of the movie
by the end of this video the creepy
things start happening just didn't make
sense to me however we get into the
forest and then I actually started
enjoying myself in this movie it's not
the smoothest execution I've ever seen
but I did enjoy the movie for what it
was and I also enjoyed this movie for
what it was going for which was more of
a psychological thriller rather than you
know you cliche average as ghost story
it did try to overreach a bit because
it's not as smart as the movie wants to
be but I have seen much worse guys let
alone in January I feel like if you're a
fan of this genre you're gonna enjoy
yourself too that is if you are a fan of
this genre I'm just saying if generally
speaking you don't like movies like this
it's not gonna win you over but as a
person who has drudged through some
shitty ass ghost stories in the past few
years of his world on YouTube enjoyed
myself I did this is one of those movies
where I mean when the scene is building
in the tensions building if the movie
just knew to stop there and just let it
go it would have been better but the
movie always tries to operation has to
end every tension-filled scene with some
sort of creepy imagery you don't always
want it in your face like that sometimes
it's better to just be like I think I
saw some creepy thing maybe I didn't
maybe I'll go back to the tent
and you can save the imagery for next
time sometimes I can add to the
experience this movie didn't really know
to do that this is a scene in the tent
where I was like they got this from the
Blair Witch Project they just did I
suppose it's harder to cite this movie
for ripping it off when it's 15 years
later but I'm just saying when I was
watching the scene though it did have
differences I thought bolero
project and this movie is ultimately
there are supporting characters in the
movie here and there really the cast is
comprised of Natalie Dormer and generic
and the last part of the last act of
this movie really tries to wrap the
movie up in a way that's so rushed you
almost feel like that could have been an
entire half an hour of screen time that
they use to really flesh it out almost
like to like guys they're charging us by
the minute really wrap this [ __ ] up guys
in the end the forest isn't
groundbreaking and if you're not a fan
of this genre it's really not going to
win you over but if you are a fan with
the creepy goes John Rowe this movie
does play it more towards the
psychological aspect rather than just
the ghost aspect the intro is a little
sloppy but once you get to the forest to
solid dishing of what you came for and
in that I think you're gonna have a good
time in this movie a few jump scares are
gonna irritate you but in the end I
really felt the forest was a good time
no alcohol required alright guys so the
forest have you seen it what did you
think about it where we thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more